[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
dans le 7-8 loisirs vos idées sorties
dans le département on commence tout de
suite avec le sommaire à l'occasion de
l'événement national dialogue aux
jardins les jardins de la vallée
organise deux journées dédiées au
bien-être nous recevons etienne désir le
directeur pour nous en parler fabriquer
les objets avec des matériaux de
récupération ou des déchets tout un art
c'est l'objet d'une exposition à
guyancourt 22 artistes présentent leurs
oeuvres nous irons la découvrir enfin le
rendez-vous junior à ne pas manquer il
sera question de hip hop haussmann
vendeurs des nous fera un point sur
cette danse moderne et et énergique aux
figures impressionnantes
à noter ce dimanche le château de
breteuil accueillera la troupe du crâne
pour un nouveau spectacle destiné au
jeune public et aux familles ce théâtre
des contes présentera deux histoires le
petit chaperon rouge et arlequin le
spectacle créé en 2015 propose une
adaptation théâtrale du célèbre conte de
charles perrault et arlequin un mélange
d'extraits du médecin malgré lui de
molière et de la comptine au clair de la
lune henri-françois de breteuil le
propriétaire du château nous en dit plus
là c'est un spectacle de théâtre qui est
a pour base bien sûr les contes de
perrault très souvent et cette année ce
sera le petit chaperon rouge avec une
dizaine de comédiens de la compagnie du
crâne qui aura lieu dans le château dans
le plus grand salon du château on
appelle la grande galerie on aura deux
séances là on aura une séance à 3h30 et
une autre à 5h30 puisque la conteuse
interviendra 4h30 donc sa voix toute une
après midi
et comme toujours pas de supplément sur
le droit d'entrée habituel pour insister
alors au petit chaperon rouge
théâtralisée
[Musique]
ce week end a lieu l'événement national
dialogue au jardin plus d'une vingtaine
de paysagistes ouvrent leurs portes pour
faire découvrir leur métier au travers
de rencontres démonstrations et visites
avec nous et tiennent désir directeur
des jardins de la vallée de magny les
hameaux bonjour etienne bonjour alors
parlez nous un petit peu de cette
cinquième édition de dialogue au jardin
qu'est ce que le public pourra découvrir
ce week-end alors le public pourra
découvrir de samedi matin à dimanche
soir plusieurs événements sur le même
site d'abord des scènes de jardins
aménagés par des élèves des différentes
écoles de paysage sur le thème du
bien-être au jardin ils vont transcrire
leurs aménagements
chaque école amène son idée et puis nous
il y aura aussi des éléments de
bien-être au jardin des scènes
définitive qui sont présentes dans notre
jardin exposition toute l'année embellie
pour l'occasion forcément et puis enfin
il y aura deux conférences une
conférence le samedi avec le journaliste
chroniqueur de france 2 philippe
collignon qui est paysagiste bien sûr et
qui viendra faire une conférence sur le
bien-être au jardin voilà alors vous
avez parlé justement un petit peu de ce
sept thématiques bien-être au jardin
c'est la thématique de cette cinquième
édition de dialogue au jardin est ce que
vous nous en dire un peu plus ce qu'est
ce que qu'est ce que c'est le bien-être
au jardin alors le bien-être aux jardins
en fête c'est
cesser
d'essayer de procurer tous ces instants
inimitable au jardin c'est les soirées
d'été les dimanches après midi c'est
comment agrémenter un jardin pour qu'il
devienne un vrai lieu de plaisir et non
pas un lieu de deux punitions
juste tourner sur l'entretien fastidieux
alors justement cet événement s'est
adressé à tous les publics où il faut un
petit peu avoir la main verte pour non
absolument pas il a adressé à ceux qui
n'ont pas du tout la main verte mais qui
veulent vraiment en profiter de leur
jardin
et donc on peut leur montrer des
terrasses des fava de la piscine du spa
etc
et plein d'autres idées que l'on a mise
en scène et puis aussi pour les
passionnés de jardin bien sûr il ya
plein d'idées pour les aider à encore
embellir et leurs jardins et à se
procurer encore plus de monde en deux de
vraies sensations dans le jardin là vous
en avez parlé également de cette
conférence samedi à 15h de philippe
collignon est ce que c'est une venue
exceptionnelle pour vous oui alors du
coup dialogue au jardin c'était un
événement national est
un événement national et bien paysagiste
nationalement connus donc philippe
cognon
viendra débattre avec l'ensemble des 35
paysagiste de qui organise dialogo
jardin à travers la france la
vidéoconférence pourra relayer cette
conférence bien sûr et nous avons
j'allais dire l' avantage de recevoir en
personne philippe collignon chez nous
alors pouvez vous nous en dire un peu
plus sur ce personnage justement sur cet
homme quels travaux at il réalisé que le
grand public pourrait connaître alors
c'est un bon il est présent et
chroniqueur sur france 2 tous les matins
et il vient expliquer que ce soit la
technique du jardin ou ou comment par l'
architecture agrémenter son jardin et
c'est aussi un paysagiste
voilà même s'il ya un peu moins de temps
pour venir pour venir faire quelques
jardins et un mot justement sur les
jardins de la vallée vous existez depuis
97 et vous avez été labellisé jardin
d'excellence c'est une distinction
importante
oui c'est un label en fait c'est un
label qui permet de définir une
entreprise qui est capable de réaliser
un aménagement
de a à z c'est à dire du bureau d'études
jusqu'à la réalisation bien sûr tout ça
en interne et jusqu'au service après
vente qui elle entretient et c est ce
que vous avez réalisé un petit peu comme
travaux justement c'est vraiment du
l'aménagement des jardins des gens ou
est ce qu'il ya des lieux publics que
vous avez oui alors nous on est
spécialisé plutôt dans l'aménagement on
aime bien créer de a à z un jardin donc
chez le particulier
donc là effectivement on travaille dans
toute la région après pour les commandes
publiques oui pour pour un show on a
aménagé par exemple en plein coeur du
duc de la zone rouge ce qu'on appelle de
la coop interne le jardin pour
représenter pour représenter cet
événement là et ce week-end l'idée c'est
vraiment de faire découvrir votre métier
au public exactement d'accord pas super
bass est notée en tout cas merci
beaucoup etienne désir d'être venu sur
notre plateau pour parler de cet
événement alors que vous ayez la main
verte ou non les jardins de la vallée
sont prêts à vous accueillir plus
d'informations sur le site internet on
passe maintenant à l'art et au recyclage
transformer un objet du quotidien ou des
déchets en oeuvre d'art c'est l'objet
d'une exposition à guyancourt dans nos
artistes présentent leurs oeuvres
réalisées à partir de matériaux de
récupération
elle est à visiter jusqu'au 11 décembre
découverte en images
[Musique]
un mur végétal en bouchons de plastique
des fusils en boîte de conserve et
pièces de bois à guyancourt la
récupération devient une oeuvre d'art
cette exposition nouveau cycle propose
une réflexion sur la relation que nous
entretenons avec notre environnement on
regroupe 22 artistes quignon
pour à peu près 80 oeuvres donc c'est
vraiment une présentation total on a
essayé vraiment de regrouper différentes
catégories de matériaux l'objectif de
cette exposition est effectivement de
pouvoir montrer les différents versants
et les différents artistes on a pu
rassembler ici autour des matériaux de
récupération et de recyclage mais
également de pouvoir montrer comment
l'humanité agit sur son à travers des
créations artistiques
articulé en trois parties machine
humanité et nature nouveau cycle
s'interroge sur le devenir de nos
créations humaines le visiteur est
invité à découvrir l'angio note de
francs soit rebih un ange gardien fait
de plastique
où
les tableaux de chaix réalisé à partir
des tic est de fruits et légumes
c'est lui parce que par le biais de
supports que j'ai trouvé assez fascinant
le jour où j'ai découvert ça offre une
véritable palette de matières de
couleurs de formes
qui par la répétition l'accumulation
l'agglutination
et l'organisation
permettent des voies explorées qui sont
passés
la france produit environ 345 millions
de tonnes de déchets par an jusqu'au 11
décembre dans le cadre de cette
exposition la ville organise des
ateliers autour de l'art et du recyclage
afin de sensibiliser le public
le mondial de l'automobile ouvre ses
portes ce samedi plus d'un million de
visiteurs sont attendus jusqu'au 16
octobre les plus grands constructeurs du
monde présentent leurs derniers modèles
et ses constructeurs sont justement
basée à saint quentin en yvelines du
centre de recherche de renault à
guyancourt au siège de mercedes france à
montigny le bretonneux les yvelines sont
même le premier département automobile
de france de nombreuses pme sont
impliqués dans la production sur ces
images vous faire vous pouvez apercevoir
quelques unes des vedettes du salon qui
côtoient les véhicules de luxe d image
signée patrick jacques de dixmude
ce samedi 1er octobre c'est aussi la
nuit de la création à versailles une
nuit dédiée à l'art qui propose un
parcours reliant une douzaine de sites à
la marée h à la maréchalerie pardon
centre d'art contemporain il sera
possible de visiter l'exposition sur des
territoires fluide jusqu'à une heure du
matin l'exposition réunit trois artistes
et questionne sur le rapport entre le
corps humain et l'habitat qui
l'entourent elle inaugure la saison 2016
2017 de la maréchalerie et est à
découvrir jusqu'au 11 décembre valérie
cno shell directrice de ce centre d'art
nous en dit plus
le propos est de montrer dans ce dans ce
projet d'exposition qui rassemble didier
fiuza faustino till roeskens et laurent
tixador de révéler
en fait comment le sujet du territoire
du paysage de l'environnement de
l'espace en général dont des des
questions des sujets propres aussi à
l'architecturé sont aussi des vecteurs
d'expérimentation de recherche de
création artistique pour ces trois
artistes de là comme chaque vendredi
dans le site 8 loisirs une séquence
dédiée exclusivement aux juniors
aujourd'hui c'est haussmann vendeur dès
qu'il vous propose de les initier au hip
hop bonsoir haussmann bonsoir camille et
en plus on prend la direction de
guyancourt et plus précisément de
gymnase de l'aviation on va à la
rencontre de l'association jade et de sa
directrice charismatique maria mendy
elle donne des cours pour des
adolescents de 10 à 12 ans je vous dis
juste regarder c'est comme pour un peu
tous les sports je vais dire c'est à
dire que déjà on est en contact avec
d'autres enfants
la patience
le travail la régularité
ça peut aider au niveau scolaire aussi
parce que à force
d'être rigoureux et de tenir bon sur des
choses qui sont pas forcément faciles et
d'y arriver voilà c'est
c'est un équilibre avec un peu un peu
tous les éléments en fait où là il faut
donc être à un vrai sportif pour faire
du vrai sportif mais surtout tout le
monde peut en faire mais il faut juste
être très persévérant et en plus des
cours s'adressent à des personnes allant
de 4 ans jusqu'à 77 ans donc vraiment l
esi est alors c'est vrai que les parents
peuvent avoir des appréhensions par
rapport à certaines figures ou autre
mais l'association jade elle existe
depuis 20 ans et sa directrice est l'une
des pionnières en fait en cirrhose dans
le hip hop dans la région et puis vous
allez voir ses élèves ils sont vraiment
et cours écoutez bien ce qui me plaît
c'est que âme ça bouge
il ya du rythme
et que comme ça ça ça libère mes
sentiments cours alors depuis quand il
fait du hip hop bah ça fait un an alors
qu'est ce qui est vraiment le top bah
j'ai moins le rythme la musique
j'aime bien bouger aussi et puis c'est
en fait plus deux ans doit y avoir
d'autres choses qui peuvent se croiser
dans ces 2 toutefois
à
donc quand on sera grand pour à refaire
pour apprendre à plusieurs thérapies en
personne par avec un homme marié alors
maintenant que vous avez convaincu par
bonds les parents et leurs enfants est
il encore possible de s'inscrire lui il
reste de la place je l'attendais cette
question aussi bien en danse hip hop
cambrai coup encore en youth talent qui
est du pop mais en danse debout donc
n'hésitez pas rendez vous sur le site de
l'association jade qui est www pour jade
tirer dans ce point fr merci haussmann
pour cette découverte peut être des
futures stars du hip hop verront le jour
parmi nos jeunes spectateurs on passe
maintenant à l'agenda les rendez vous à
noter pour ce week end
on commence par les sportifs la
troisième édition de tu viens tu cours
c'est demain à villiers saint frédéric
petit ou grand le principe est simple
courir quel que soit son niveau
plusieurs parcours sont proposés allant
de 1 à 24 km magny les hameaux ouvre sa
saison culturelle ce samedi à 20 heures
avec un spectacle familial les désaxés
un quatuor de saxophonistes déjanté
mêlant théâtre musique et humour
c'est la fin de 7,8 loisirs merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis je vous
retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro 10 il a très bon week-end
à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]